Film Courage: Writing every day, is this a
myth or a must for an author?
Jennifer Brody: It’s kind of a must.
I mean, I think that we go through different
periods where we are incubating ideas or working
on ideas.
The thing I think about when having a regular
writing practice is that it gets you into
the mode of producing pages all the time.
And I think also for me when I work into a
story, I’m in the world of the story and
I’m always kind of walking around in that
world.
And so it’s a much more seamless process
when I go to sit down to work.
If I take a few days off and go back, it takes
time to work back into the story for me.
So I lose time just by being out of it and
then coming back in.
So I think writing everyday will help with
that because it keeps you in the story.
And keeps you moving through it.
But I also always say, it’s amazing how
the amount of time you spend writing actually
equals more pages.
It’s not like people think there is some
crazy formula to it.
I’m like “No it really is time in equals
time out.”
And some days are going to be better writing
days than others.
So it’s not to say that every day you sit
down you’re going to have this amazing output.
Some writers have word counts that they do
per day.
I have never done that for myself.
A lot of times it is just giving yourself
permission to write what we call (well, I
won’t say) “The Crappy First Draft”
or “The Bad First Draft.”
So you kind of free yourself from the perfectionism
that is really what Writer’s Block is.
Writer’s Block is really feeling the perfectionism
and thinking that writing will be not as good
as what you want it to be.
And once the fear of not writing overwhelms
that, that’s usually when we start writing.
So giving yourself permission to write something
that isn’t as good as you want it to be
on the first pass.
And then a lot of times sitting down and saying
“It’s okay, you can write a paragraph.
That’s okay.”
And then usually once I write a paragraph
I’ll be in it and be writing away.
But saying like (if you sit down) “I have
to write 10 pages.”
That can get overwhelming in and of itself,
because that’s a lot of pages.
So just being kind of like a little bit flexible
in how much you are really putting out.
But yeah, I would say writing every day is
somewhat important.
Film Courage: And where do you write?
Where do you do your best writing?
Jennifer Brody: It started out where I would
write at home most of the time but now I kind
of call it the Great Coffee Shop Rotation,
which is to say that I move around to a lot
of different coffee shops.
I might have two shifts where one is a coffee
shop and then I come home and work more (especially
when I am under a very crazy deadline like
I am right now).
And there are other writers that I know at
a lot of these coffee shops.
It becomes kind of a community and you know
some of them are screenwriters or doing different
types of things.
So I have my friends that I see and it’s
a little bit like going to an office.
With being home a lot which some people do
do their best writing, it can be a little
bit where you get distracted because it’s
like the hundred things you need to do like
unload the dishwasher, unload the bed, do
this, do that.
So leaving the house kind of gets you away
from all of that plus coffee (good coffee).
So that’s kind of where I do it now.
And then I do things like my parents live
in Virginia in the country.
So sometimes I’ll go out there for a couple
of weeks and take it kind of like a working
retreat.
I also try to go on a lot of workshops and
residencies.
So I did one in Tuscany last year and I am
actually going to Provence to work with some
writers.
Actually at Julia Child’s old house.
It’s a cooking and writing retreat.
But I found that sometimes the travel and
being around other authors is really conducive
to creativity.
Plus you are getting feedback and you’re
getting workshopping.
So that aspect is nice, too.
I always try to do stuff like that.
Film Courage: And how, do you write on a laptop?
Do you use just a legal pad?
Jennifer Brody: I write on a laptop and I
use Word, even thought I want to learn Scrivener
and I hear there is a learning curve and I’m
scared.
Scrivener is a software that a lot of authors
swear by and use.
And then I write on a laptop but I do have
a little notebook I carry where I will scribble
down ideas.
Also, it depends on what stage of writing
I am in, but when I am drafting a story, I’ll
have a lot of ideas that pop up in the middle
of the night or in the shower or when I am
walking.
So I end up emailing myself a lot of notes.
Or even sometimes I’ll sketch out whole
scenes on my cellphone especially if I am
not at home or with my computer, just like
“Oh…here’s what I am thinking.”
And so I will email it to myself and I’ll
have it.
Because inspiration pops up at all hours of
the day and the night.